unfortunately in Texas there is a
obscenity exemption clause in the law
and so if it's used in an educational
for an educational purpose then it's
allowed and that's what they're hiding
behind they're saying it violates the
child's first amendment rights to pull
these books off of the Shelf which I
mean I spoke to that in my first video
it's like really I mean are we violating
their second amendment rights when we
tell them they can't carry a gun to
school no because they're children we're
talking about children they don't have
the same rights that we do as adults for
good reason so are we violating their
third amendment rights when we quarter
British soldiers in there well done
never mind that's another good question
plenty of other examples no of course we
I mean since when does the first
amendment protect your right to be act
able to access any book you want at a
specific Library period even if you're
an adult but but then second of all to
suggest that children have this right do
children have the right to say whatever
they want in schools I don't think so